good morning Hank it's Sunday February
22nd and today I am going to present you
with real unassailable evidence that oil
companies are ripping you off through
the evil magic of demon mathematics now
hey before we start I want to say for
the record that just because oil
companies are ripping us off does not
mean that gas is too expensive
in fact think even at the very height of
the 2008 oil bubble a gallon of gasoline
was still less expensive than a gallon
of fierce grape Gatorade which strikes
me as just a little bit odd since oil
must be mined from the depths of the
earth shipped across the world than
refined then trucked to a gas station
and sunk into a gigantic underground
container whereas to produce beer
scraped Gatorade I believe all you have
to do is milk purple alligators but all
that said I've never been able to shape
the suspicion that oil companies were
ripping me off and it turns out I am
totally right ok Hank so I believe you
and I both have the same third grade
teacher miss pink and so you may
remember when this thing taught us the
rules of rounding you know if you're
rounding to the nearest whole number
four point six becomes five four point
four becomes four etc miss pink of
course taught us that you round one to
four down and five to nine up well Hank
it turns out that miss pink was a dirty
liar in cahoots with Big Oil because if
you round one to four down and five to
nine up you end up rounding down four
Knights of the time and rounding up five
ninths of the time there is actually a
fair system of rounding called Dutch
rounding in which you round one to four
down six to nine up and then you round
five up or down based on the numbers
around it but when it comes to the
fractional pennies in your gasoline
purchases you will never guess which
system of rounding the oil companies use
unless you guess that they use the one
that gets in the extra penny one
twentieth of the time that's right Hank
five percent of American gasoline
purchases are charging extra penny
because of stupid unfair third grade
rounding now I know you're thinking Hank
you're thinking say go to the gas
station once a week that means on
average I lose about two and a half
pennies per year
well first off if not two and a half
pennies according to the oil companies
it's three days and second off it's
actually millions of dollars every
single year Hank the whole oil company
stealing people's money by a rounding
reminds me of something that Abraham
Lincoln once said he said you can fool
some of the people all the time and all
the people some of the time but you
can't fool all the people all the time
unless it's a question of math then you
can in fact fool all the people all the
time so Hank that's this week's
installment of why mathematics matters I
did some calculations and even though I
haven't owned a car for a lot of my
adult life Exxon owes me about eight
pennies so I wrote them a letter
explaining the rules of rounding that
they've been exploiting for decades and
asked for my eight cents back I'll let
you know how it
oh and Hank you may be wondering why
touch rounding is called Dutch rounding
allow me to read to you from Wikipedia
the term Dutch rounding originated
during the Dutch Golden Age this period
of wealth was characterized by opulent
feasts where many prominent Dutch men
grew round Oh Wikipedia with your
attention between those who would share
knowledge and those who would destroy it